do you guys get like have like a
honeymoon period with your videos where
you have like this after you've finished
like a big project or something you like
the first two three days
you go through every comment you're just
reading it all the time and then it just
and then you kind of just don't care
about it anymore you move on i said
exactly well because because youtube
forces you to be like oh you've
you've secured cancer all right now cure
cure something else please
that's like it's it's like it's no
matter what you do it's never that's a
terrible analogy by the way
it's never good enough for you the
victory lap is always short right yeah
yeah like
it doesn't matter how big or how amazing
you did i mean like look at the like
unasanas that channel right like they
did like
a whole year's worth of content deleted
it it was a giant thing and now they
have to get on about it
yeah it's it's it's weird how it's weird
and scary how short
internet memory is crazy it's like
eunice annis is was
an amazing concept an amazing idea and
it's like so impressive that they pulled
it off
like but how long is it gonna actually
remain in people's memories you reckon
it's it's gonna be tough it's hard to
say because there's
like basically all evidence of it has
been removed now
they wanted do you know what that is by
the way luckily so there's these guys
there's these two youtubers well
markiplier is one of them oh
and cranky ethan they basically did a
channel where they uploaded daily
and at the end of it they were taking it
all down yeah so that was the whole
process
in latin means one year right so
basically they would upload every day
for
365 days and then on the 365th day they
would delete their channel and they did
and interesting concepts yeah and then
they they take down any videos that are
re-uploaded so the whole point of it was
to be like in the memory of the people
yeah it's quite cool
really cool but again it's one of those
things just like oh my god they pulled
it off they had videos that long and
then now it's like
okay cool now what like like the only
thing that remains now is like just the
merch
that's literally what it's like being a
youtuber and like making content on the
internet yeah yeah well you know i was
always morbid because i was always
watching casey neistat back when he was
starting to blow up and doing daily
vlogs and this man was literally sharing
like
every aspect of his life yeah and then
it's still like but we want more
like what else do you have show is
everything and it's like this man is
literally
like doing everything the world has to
offer yeah youtube is like come on
keep going and then he stops and then
you know his channel didn't do
very well for a while didn't he grow up
he took a break because obviously gonna
get burned out from doing that oh yeah
but now he's back i think he's doing
like
sparingly he seems to be happy yeah he's
usually pretty chill yeah that's crazy
though it
scares me that what just having to do
that like
i think my version of hell is daily
uploads
daily vlogs and then having to edit that
said daily vlog because
it's not just daily vlogs it was like
highly produced yeah
it was like kind of like what you were
trying to do across japan
the first one let's not talk about that
me grumbling for like four hours playing
a video game and then just
doing nothing
you know what i'd be like in the room
with you be like wow
i've always i've always wanted you know
how you see those like those really like
shitty bbc like three documentaries
about like
unamusing things and like the youtuber
ones i really want like a like a bbc
four or something to come and be like
follow me for a day
exposure and just be like yeah so i just
kind of sit here all day really and just
chat
[ __ ] online i mean just however you've
been playing league for the past
uh what what now it's like oh maybe
another form we're going to talk to
people online for three hours
get angry and then might go jacqueline
in the life of a youtuber
yeah connor's gonna go to the
supermarket and eat food like normal
humans
and then go back to his house and eat it
but with that voiceover it kind of works
and maybe the kid he could sell it to me
that's that's a good concept i would
i really want to do something like that
just so i can like [ __ ] with the footage
constantly while i'm recording like put
this in keep that out
like you think about doing like daily
videos
that's scary that's a lot of work chris
you're not the editor
no but what would i do daily like would
it be like like the way that you did the
the fuji video where it's like go on a
journey
across
perhaps transportation across japan
moving across nippon each day a
different form of transport a bicycle a
skateboard a horse
i would watch that i feel like we're
building something here i feel like i
you shouldn't give me a horse because i
already call people peasants like
unironically i think that'll that'll
raise the bar you know what i mean
like fully dressed hello peasants